we're hearing some harrowing stories
from lawmakers about their experiences
that day
in an instagram live feed last night
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
recalled the traumatic events
inside the capitol and the aftermath
brought forth another painful memory
from her past
start to hear these yells of
where is she where is she
and
i just thought to myself they got inside
and so i hide behind my door
like this like i'm here and the bathroom
door starts going like this
this was the moment where
i thought everything
was over these folks who tell us
to move on that it's not a big deal that
we should forget what's happened
or even telling us to apologize
um these are the same tactics of abusers
and um
i'm a survivor of sexual assault
um and i haven't told many people that
in my life
um but
when we go through trauma
trauma compounds on each other i
have hesitated to tell this story has to
do with some of that trauma
you know um as a survivor
um i struggle with the idea
of being believed this is why we wanted
to spend
some time talking about this this is not
about her policies or politics it's
about our shared humanity
and as reporters we've covered stories
where people have survived wars
sexual assault mass tragic events
and this is what they say that it takes
days weeks
months years sometimes never for them to
fully get over
what they witnessed and that other that
other traumas trigger
memories of the previous trauma no we
saw it with cicely tyson who at 96
teared up when she talked about someone
who tried to force her to do something
she didn't want to do but
to go back to aoc for just a second i i
thought
number one i so applaud her for talking
about something that's so painful and so
private
and you could see why she's traumatized
by when they say where is she you know
at first people thought it was nancy
pelosi but she's so recognizable
who knows what could have happened her
degree she's happy inside that building
yes she did
she sure did all right thank you vlad